it's a possible futures billions of
deaths we've got to stop you from a
notion so what do we do first we can
still change the future
welcome the first one I have to prepare
the team for this crisis
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone we got brand new
flash brand-new Smallville Superman to
talk about there's even a birds-of-prey
trailer coming up that I'll talk about
at the end of the video - they're still
filming the very first episode of the
crossover right now so we'll break it
all down and if you're brand new to the
channel I'll be doing Easter egg videos
trailer videos all season long for all
the crisis stuff so be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'll also be doing special giveaways
every week because crisis is such a big
deal so I'll explain that at the end of
the video - I'll talk about the Superman
Smallville stuff that they're doing
right now then I'll talk about the
negative flash scene if you're big flash
comic book fan they're doing a lot of
really big comic-book stuff from the
rebirth era recently they just posted a
new scene of Tom Welling Superman
hanging out with Tyler hoechlin Superman
and his version of Lois Lane because
Erica Durance Lois Lane is nowhere to be
found in this I'm assuming that it's Tom
Welling Superman who's come from
Smallville earth to earth 38 supergirls
Smallville earth to hang out with Tyler
hoechlin Superman what's going on with
the crossover this is the schedule is
that the Supergirl episode is the first
episode so most of the episode will
probably take place on super girls earth
38 which means that at some point early
in the episode either someone from Team
flash or one of the Supergirl characters
will have to go to Smallville's earth to
grab Tom Welling Superman and tell him
what's going on with crisis on Infinite
Earths and then bring him into the fray
to join the fight so this kind of
confirms that they do have bigger plans
for Tom Welling Superman even Marc
Guggenheim this morning was saying we've
been planning this crossover for 10
years earlier Stephen Amell said that
there would be no crossover if not for
Tom Welling in the Smallville TV show so
Tom Welling gets to be in the crossover
meaning that they probably have a much
bigger role than we imagined for him
remember last season when they had a
whole bunch of Tyler hoechlin Superman
in every single episode in a whole bunch
of his Lois Lane they did this whole
subplot with them getting married and
then her getting pregnant then going
away to Argo City at the end of that so
she could give birth to John Kent in
safety so they're back now she clearly
doesn't look like she's pregnant anymore
so I'm assuming a full years come and
she's given birth to that baby wherever
it winds up in the episode but hopefully
that makes you feel a little bit better
about what they're doing with Tom
Welling Superman during the crossover
like he's not gonna show up for five
minutes and then just disappear it
doesn't really say a lot about what
they're doing with the other Smallville
characters and obviously they still
haven't confirmed which other Smallville
actors that are going to they're still
trying to get Lynda Carter Wonder Woman
but it seems like that might actually
wind up happening now so there might be
a version of Wonder Woman during the
crossover - I've already talked a lot
about Batman but moving into the
negative flash stuff so this is stuff
for the main arc and the first half of
the season in the flash TV shows it sort
of leads into crisis on Infinite Earths
slightly different from the Superman
Smallville stuff that's going on
recently they just finished filming
either Episode seven or eight of the
flash this season all the crossovers are
going to be in early December so it'll
be Episode nine of all the TV shows the
mid-season finale it makes sense because
there's gonna be a big break in the
crossover based on the way the schedule
looks the first three episodes of the
crossover will air at the beginning of
December then they'll go on break for
the holiday then come back in January
then the second half of the crossover
will air so because they're filming that
first episode of the crossover right now
this negative flash scene that they're
filming for the flash TV show is
probably from episode 8 if you haven't
been reading the flash rebirth comics a
couple years ago when they started that
they did a negative flash arc where the
reverse flash effectively pushes the
flash Barry Allen into the negative
Speed Force
it basically poisons him then he emerges
from the negative Speed Force this
really monstrous looking version of
himself and they just called him the
negative flash because he was full of
negative Speed Force they kind of did
something like that with Nora last
season during flash season 5 where
reverse flash sort of tricked her into
using the negative Speed Force as if it
were the dark side of the force
talking about star wars Easter eggs
pieces and suddenly
are no longer you
part of something different now part of
a negative force
[Music]
even though I wasn't completely happy
with what they did with that part of the
arc her Breaking Bad entering the
negative Speed Force which is sort of a
set for the concept of the negative
flash even though they didn't roll super
hard on Nora
negative flash the reason why people
think that this is negative flash is
because if you look at his fingertips
they're looking like claws and that's
basically what the negative flashes
hands look like obviously the rest of it
will be CG his lightning changes colors
a little bit he gives off black
lightning in the comics but it's kind of
hard to pull off with the TV special
effects so his lightning on the TV show
when he's negative flash might be a
slightly different color but a lot of
people just wondering why he would go
negative flash right before the
crossover and if it has something to do
with crisis on Infinite Earths because
the negative Speed Force gives you a lot
of different types of flash powers than
the positive regular speed forces you
would consider it so the negative speed
force is the sort of buffer to the
time-space continuum
that's how reverse flash has been able
to survive all the timeline changes into
present day that's how we still have
this version of Tom Cavanagh reverse
flash in the future if you're wondering
how he survived all the major major
flashpoint timeline changes the past
couple of seasons so the first half of
the season is all about Barry and team
flash trying to avoid his eventual
impending death disappearing during
crisis that would be one solution for
them but it also might have something to
do with the blood work argh
we also have some new information about
what's going on the second half of the
season with a brand new villain I know
everybody wants to see Red Death just as
I was getting ready to make this video
they announced that Sendhil Ramamurthy
the person who's playing the blood work
character the same actor from Heroes
everybody making all kinds of heroes
jokes when he's on screen he just joined
another TV show that's gonna be filming
early next year when he would normally
be filming flash episodes so he just
seemingly confirms that he will not be
around the second half of the season the
children are kind of implied that there
will be a different bill in the second
half but TV show people say things all
the time to try and mislead you this
just confirms that there will probably
be some other giant big villain the
second half of the season after crisis
here's the thing about Red Death though
they've already teased it during the
flash-forwards when we got the noir
episode for the last year even though
they've wiped that timeline
we're still getting god speed during the
flash
season 6 episode 1 somehow somewhere
from the multiverse a God speed appears
so they're bringing that back it's true
that they're probably going to bring a
version of Red Death back albeit a
slightly different version than the one
that was name dropped during this future
noir episode at the flash museum early
speculation is they're gonna make Red
Death a speedster they could just turn
it into a negative flash situation
although I don't think that they would
roll hard on an evil version of Barry
fighting himself during the season again
so just expect a couple big changes to
Red Death if they're gonna roll hard on
that this scene of reverse-flash
teaching Nora how to enter the negative
Speed Force and utilize it is a bit of a
dark twist on the speech that he gave to
Barry you're one with the Speed Force
when he was teaching him out of phase
during flash season 1 it's meant to be
the evil version of that one of the best
reverse flash scenes from last season
now in the comics reverse flash sort of
tricked Barry into poisoning himself
with negative Speed Force so just expect
them to have a fun twist on that comic
book arc because he was negative flash
when blood work showed up in the comics
so of course blood work as the villain
the first half of the season here they
would do some negative Speed Force stuff
but in related Superman crossover news
they're gonna be filming the crossover
episodes for the next month or so so
we're gonna get way more pictures behind
the scenes clips of them doing really
cool stuff I'll try to include that and
all the big crossover Easter Egg videos
that I do week to week so no worries I'm
hoping we get some pictures of older
Kevin Conroy Batman at some point too
but they might keep those close to the
vest they did say that they were
planning on dropping a couple more big
reveals and promos pretty soon though so
just expect to hear more big crisis
stuff going on
they even just posted that preview of
Brandon Ralph going full Kingdom Come
Superman this actually looks great he's
probably gonna be one of the bigger
characters during the crossover talking
about which version of Superman they
spend the most time with remember his
version of Superman is sort of an older
version of the Christopher Reeve
Superman because his Superman film
Superman Returns was meant to be a sort
of sequel to Superman 2 in the really
good news is they finally confirmed that
they're dropping the brand new official
birds of prey trailer the full trailer
tomorrow so that will be my next big DC
video it's just the beginning and what's
happening is is I'll do flash ring
giveaway every week till we get closer
to the cross
then I might change it to something a
little bit more special just based on
people's suggestions all you have to do
to enter those is be a subscriber and
leave your best crisis on Infinite
Earths theory on the video while you
wait for everything click here for all
my flash season 6 and crossover trailer
videos and click here for that brand new
Rick and Morty's season 4 teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]